this is amazing to be here on this  journey  i cannot believe i'm here and what a  journey has been it's another  history-making moment at the 2022 oscars  as troy kotzer becomes the first deaf  man to win an academy award for his role  in coda troy is just the second deaf  person to win his co-star marlee matlin  was the first who won best actress back  in 1986. during his acceptance speech  troy dedicated his award to the deaf  community and paid an emotional tribute  to his father my dad he was the best  signer  in our family  but he was in a car accident  and he became paralyzed from the neck  down  and he no longer was able to sign  dad  i learned so much from you  i'll always love you  you are my hero  oscar rounds out his long list of  accolades for his role in coda including  best supporting actor at the bafta  critics choice and sag awards